breaking news berkshire hathaway stock
just hit an all-time high warren buffett
obviously for years now people have been
wondering he hadn't outperformed the s p
500 had he lost his touch charlie munger
they did their annual live stream
conversation their press conference from
omaha what is going on with berkshire
hathaway well they just hit an all-time
high do we think that uh warren buffett
still is as good as he's ever been or
just because they hit an all-time high
doesn't necessarily mean that they uh
still have their touch like they didn't
miss out on the technology industry yeah
some of this stuff
takes years to play out right
investments he's making today or
yesterday or tomorrow not aren't
necessarily going to reflect in their
share price uh within the next month two
months six months two years even right
so i think when you think about in that
context a lot of the investments that he
has already made uh have been playing
out and have played out he's an
incredible investor he's done a great
job he understands compounding and the
power of that better than anyone
probably so i think when you look at his
portfolio absolutely he's done a great
job i think the the the complaint that a
lot of people have against him is like
how does it look when he when he moves
right from a new to a new generation
there's obviously been a digital
transformation he has probably missed
out on uh more of this of the tech
stocks than uh
then he made right he's obviously
invested in some of the companies but
he's missed out on a lot also i think
part of that is him just understanding
what he's good at and investing in those
businesses he likes certain things that
that are uh our value investment uh
thesis right and he has invested in
those for a long period of time but i
think he gets a bad rap within the
crypto community specifically right
because he has not only missed that boat
relative to kind of where we are today
but he has had a very bad attitude
towards a lot of it and he's been very
outspoken about some of these things so
ultimately i think people are just
saying hey look you understand one thing
really really really well but you don't
understand this other thing at all
really so sure maybe i'll take advice
from you on that thing but i certainly
won't take it i won't take advice from
you on this new stuff over the last five
years berkshire hathaway is up 96.7
is their class a shares so 96.7
the s p 500 over the last five years is
up
105.2 percent so even over the last five
years although berkshire hathaway has
hit a all-time high today they haven't
outperformed the s p 500 over the last
five years you would have made more
money in the s p and you would have
saved money not buying flights to omaha
to go worship him
but but i mean again it goes to show
that it's very very hard to do this now
i would actually argue even though they
actually didn't keep up uh perfectly
with the s p 500 they definitely didn't
beat it deploying that much money is
incredibly difficult so they have 245
billion dollars of revenue every year uh
based on 2020 numbers they employ over
360 000 people across their companies
and so it's hard when you have a balance
sheet i think they have over 100 billion
dollars of cash on their balance sheet
right just that alone is going to drag
performance if you've got all that
capital sitting there it's eating away
at the purchasing power at some point
you got to do something but i do think
that it's interesting he still hasn't
outperformed the s p 500 over the last
five years uh but the stock hits an
all-time high now the s p 500 hit an
all-time high 70 times last year right
so there is something to uh to kind of
pay attention to there but when you
start to look at this stuff the other
thing that uh i think people forget as
part of the analysis is he isn't
necessarily trying to optimize for
beating the s p 500 uh what he's
optimizing for is how does he deploy
this to continue to drive cash flow
right and that's where i think uh it
becomes pretty interesting so uh the
market cap of the class b shares is 700
billion and that's also about 96 so
class a class b shares of berkshire both
about 96 percent whereas the s p 500 is
up 105 over the last uh five years or so
john what do you think
i think the worst investments that they
are making aren't showing up on their
balance sheet in the sense of missed
opportunities since technology has
boomed so much in the last 20 years i
think he's a very good investor and a
very long-term thinker um that spans
across generational um investments right
so he's investing in stuff that i think
will have and hold value in 10 to 15
years as well as in five years right and
a lot of people looking for a very short
term high returns and he's i think
making safer bets in in a
longer time horizon
yeah uh someone in the chat red has made
a good point which is that it discounts
the dividends too that uh the total
return for the s p would be much higher
if you can resolve that in there also in
the compounding yeah i'm just comparing
like for like just the stock price not
including dividends for anybody anything
just like for like the other the other
thing i was going to say very quickly
though is part of this uh uh kind of
all-time high for berkshire hathaway
again over generalization but a lot of
investors right now are saying okay i
was in risk on assets those risk on
assets are going to become kind of in
the crosshairs because interest rates
potentially are going to get raised here
if they get raised people are going to
know that the risk assets sell off so
before that happens what i'm going to do
is i'm going to sell my risk assets my
tech stocks my growth stocks uh my
crypto et cetera and i'm going to move
my money from the risk assets into more
value type investing and guess what
berkshire hathaway is like the the meme
lord of all value investing and so it
doesn't surprise me that berkshire
hathaway hits an all-time high at the
exact moment that uh in an over
generalized way people are rotating out
of the growth stocks and the risk assets
into more value type investments in
hindsight yeah that makes a ton of sense
as to why people would be doing that is
they're seeking kind of safety in
something like a berkshire versus
holding onto the tech stocks that have
done really well obviously over the last
you know 12 24 months whatever